[Music]
in our series vaccinating america we're
looking at efforts to spread a positive
message
about covet vaccines vice president
pence is being vaccinated on camera this
morning
in an effort to build confidence among
americans
a series of ad campaigns in the coming
weeks will try to educate people about
vaccine safety
and effectiveness cbs news chief medical
correspondent dr john lapook
looks at how the ads will address
concerns and may involve
some high profile celebrities
friends don't let friends drive drunk
from warnings about drinking and driving
mcgruff here i want you to learn a song
to taking a bite out of crimes
and iconic figures like smokey the bear
public service campaigns have long
played an important role in educating
the public
our goal is to have the right message
now the ad council
the non-profit behind those campaigns is
working on a new project
spreading the word about the coronavirus
vaccine
ad council president lisa sherman says
their campaigns will be far-reaching
uh broadcast television it's going to be
radio it's going to be
digital and social platforms celebrities
that we're talking about
and it could be you could go to church
on sunday and hear a message from your
minister
the ad council largely runs on donations
they secured 400 million dollars in
donated media for their covet campaigns
such as ads that started rolling out in
march encouraging people to mask up
and wash their hands that's roughly four
times what they received from messaging
about hurricane katrina is there a
challenge you're facing right now which
was unexpected the biggest challenge is
just getting underneath the complicated
nature of
of what makes people hesitant for some
it's really just i need to understand
that this is safe for me and my family
dr anthony fauci says roughly 70 to 85
percent of americans will need to get a
covet vaccine in order to achieve herd
immunity
the percentage of willing people has
been slowly climbing in recent months
from 63 in september to 71 percent now
in the past familiar faces have been
used to boost vaccine confidence
including royalty on both sides of the
atlantic
in 1956 elvis presley got the polio
vaccine in front of reporters
and queen elizabeth announced her
children prince charles and princess
anne
had also received it dr francis collins
is head of the national institutes of
health
who is today's elvis presley oh i think
we need a bunch of elvis presleys i
would sure like to see
beyonce let's get oprah
let's get a bunch of athletes maybe a
few doctors
like the ad council the national
institutes of health says when it comes
to covet vaccine messaging
it's not a one-size-fits-all approach
how do you figure out
which populations to target and how to
target them there's a lot of research
that's already gone on
in terms of focus groups with particular
communities to find out what is the
source of their concerns
life can be bright in america latinx
actress rita moreno says she plans to
get the coveted vaccine as soon as she
can
and is encouraging others to do the same
i think you should have
not just famous people i think you need
to have real people
who have let's say a gift for gab would
you consider taking it publicly as an
example
absolutely and i think it's a wonderful
thing that elvis presley did
and by the way uh i used to date him
he did you know that no rita we did not
know that
for cbs this morning dr john lepuc south
shaftesbury vermont
you know it now you did not know that
rita moreno
i love it
and remember to get your vaccine when
it's your turn